oh I'm so upset I just realized I went
to this place last night this is not
relevant at all but I got pickled
carrots and pickled beans and I left
them at Micah's house welcome back -
markiplier makes this time we're making
pies and pies as we all know are part of
American culture specifically and they
would put mutton in there it would put
some intestines can whoever's editing
this maybe it's me it's me
can you put a can you put a can you put
a mouse in this and a lot of blood and
real Kakori sound effects no put a mouse
in this evolution of pie came from meat
went to vegetables first not many people
know this vegetables got their way into
their pastries you got the carrot cakes
you got your potato cakes what is your
opinion on carrot cake I love it I think
it's good and everyone gives me [ __ ] for
it though okay why would everybody take
a vacation likes it it's got a really
rich not too sweet face to it especially
the the cinnamon and the Nutmeg oh yeah
most people who have cake there's still
a way too sweet yeah yeah they put too
much icing on carrot cake so good like
we did when we made cake yeah yeah yeah
yeah let's cut to the moment where we've
said cake needs to be sweeter than hell
and like every
needs to be overly sugar and now Tyler
says some random [ __ ] hey listen I
had a great dream last night was about
Mickey Mouse and he was chopping up
carrots that were screaming
alright so hi so we're gonna make some
pie we're gonna eat some pie and we're
gonna do this all with knowing that pies
are made with love and you need to have
love to make pie pie sex is great but
you ever have we have we have pie crust
mix we're not gonna use it we don't need
it
none of that not important that's why
it's really simple ingredients to make
pie crust the important thing that I've
learned from all my cooking shows that
I've seen I'm gonna keep to myself and
not tell you guys you're on your own
[ __ ] you [ __ ] I'm going to wash my
hands all good
have we learned nothing I already washed
mine which rub your washed hands on my
hands I'm doing something bad again
against for you oh wow it doesn't help
that I'm trying to measure
when I haven't measured anything else
ever in this we have
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
I'm gonna get so many bits of paper in
my seen this on the Discovery Channel or
break word sweetie you got a full blares
of butter you've got four layers of
butter that's what it is
that's what pastry is oh yes yes I am oh
god I'm gonna have a hundred layers if I
do a layer a second oh oh god this
butter leaking everything good oh god
it's so buttery and delicious oh god oh
god oh god what no countdown all right
pine crust did you just taste that all
right mine's got a little butter leakage
but I think that's okay
now we need to let these chill chill it
was not time
maybe their precious seconds I want to
give for this to exist
why'd you stick her for you're in my
house for entertainment I know
alright so we need to let it look you
need to let them chill
we will now chill for one hour to let it
chill and then we will be back with the
feelings round to our feeling is the
most important part of any pie tell them
about it
oh and you don't have a filling in your
pie you didn't have it pie
alright so we need to make the filling
but we only have so much filling you got
a lot of apples who wants to make apple
pie I'll do apples I've definitely got
enough I'm gonna do apple raspberry
blueberry pie alright this is like 10
pounds okay they're three pounds no
we're not gonna fight over it yes it's
not good court I don't know how you
didn't put the whole of the quarter all
right corny corny daddy yeah
make it eight minutes we've got eight
minutes to make it can you hurry the
hell up
I'm going as fast he's and we're gonna
see which one of us can make it faster
okay but you also have to quarter out
yeah
no I don't think that you think it's as
easy as you think it might be dude
I grew up poor we used to core apples
day-in day-out you don't tell me that's
not my heritage family yeah so we've
made money selling them the course they
just ate the course that Accord well no
well that's how my family died from all
the cyanide zoom in apple seeds there's
naturally occurring cyanide if you eat
enough apple seeds you will die from
cyanide there's one coming up baby
third one coming up baby but how many of
you have cored all of them in my part
incorrect
no I just can't bring myself to quorum
for the memories of my lost family who
all died from cyanide poisoning you
remember because I knew fourth coming up
okay but you don't have any of them card
yeah well how long do you think he's
gonna take me to call him huh a long
time that time is it okay okay call it
out every minute please thank you thank
you Amy
Oh Amy thank you thank you Amy thank you
give me thank you you're so helpful
thank you thank you
fifth one coming up baby okay take the
adverb from this video Ethan did you do
something naughty or like we need more
time no we don't need more time everyone
always says that we need more time we
don't need more time we don't need more
time can you well Tyra would you be a
doll and turn my heat on my stove what
level would you like I would like a
medium maybe you just above me I've got
seven cores and seven horse maybe it's a
why I don't have any horse
I don't know what to do my mom's calling
me alright yeah well you better answer
it maybe she'll tell you how to make
bike we can't answer it yeah you can no
I can't
what up it's impossible why why it's
just impossible or it's just simply what
I just said and now Ethan uses a knife
improperly that's working you know what
whoa
yes what you're gonna burn blue
breakfast to the stovetop no I'm just
sabotaging you what what what's up no no
doing the Middle's on oh sorry
I turned it on it doesn't know it's
right oh oh it's fine how much done
great if I like breathe on this it'll go
hotter
sweetie are you microwaving oh dude it's
not going let's just reduce keep going
back and forth
all right utensils down
[Laughter]
this is a prototype clove it's water
only one the tempering this water test
all right
well on what are you talking about no
this is a hot surface even sorry no
that's not off so we've got our we've
got our ingredients look now is time for
the coup de Gras we got to make these
pies we gotta give em in the oven and
then we got to bake them that's how this
works right okay we're gonna roll these
out shape them to the tin put our
filling in and then we got ourselves a
pie all right we have five minutes to
get it in or filling in and in the oven
sound fair that's Paris I'm fair this
[ __ ]
look the rolling thing that I got out
you know it's only family it's only fair
fair is fair okay
you can have it back now thank you so
you can do the window pane test to see
if there's been enough gluten developed
I can't see through this therefore it
passes the window pane test way are you
supposed to see through it no no that's
why it's called a window pane yes yes we
can't see through that bad boy at all
can you see my face I can't you see my
are you
are you my mommy are you my daddy right
you know you yeah okay
hot stuff coming through you could move
your plate of apples you know that right
see I'm using a slotted spatula to drain
a lot of the juices out of the way so
that it's not quite so soggy put the
flour there who's sabotaging my view
Ethan didn't put it back nothing you do
you lock in song so it was you made your
pie no I haven't yeah you have you've
got it there yeah yeah well faced pie
cheese cheese
I said you couldn't have cheese that's
right [ __ ] move your plate and move
over can you see me big knife coming
through never give up never how much
come on slowpoke smarty done oh why did
I do that how does it air blood okay
Jesus lover it's this massive ante oh
yeah sure that's a T if I had more time
five more seconds you had five seconds
you have you
you putz around there 4:30 you my baby
ever give up they're just you know give
up on life YouTube whatever Bob
gymnastics you ever just give up bro
what up yo Howard do step us too deep
mark you ever just cube up on kidneys
knees anything with an e me if it ever
goes your face looks shitty hey this is
pre oven free free galloway thumbnail
material you get out of the way flour on
me get out of the way praise blood
remember who do you think I am how do
you think is it's a good-looking pie
either all right they're going in you
guys determine how long all right - you
didn't even use so the pies have been
baking for a bit I want Tyler to see
this I want you open that open just see
what you're dealing with oh I made a
Medicaid rib cake yeah you did yeah all
that flour was hey I had to thicken it
somehow or we said no no no you did a
beautiful and you're done I think I'm
done you're happy with it yeah Wow he
presented it really quick let me see
that it smells good no quitter no we're
not quitting
quitter ready you quittin you a quitter
looks looks like you cut off someone's
face and put it on your
true the horrible a masterpiece mine
smells good because it's got character
and love you guys didn't love your pie
well no I mean that mine does rose to
the challenge listen I know what love
looks like not look like love that looks
like a curse that looks like the
opposite of love that's a pie made of
human skin I like I like the extra spin
excuse me it's kind of like a pizza
crust I'm gonna give it just a another
two seconds I didn't say the seconds had
to be sequential oh that's beautiful
that's a pretty pie looks like it was
this is a pretty pie I have to say it's
the various of the top his brain will
bring the pies over Oh these do look
tasty oh nice I think I think that's
exactly of know what pies do they seven
okay you guys fall in Oh easy good text
job okay before before we let's get a
nice shot of us all holding up our pies
for the lovely camera it's very hot oh
oh it's so hot I got it
take it get it up get it up it's alright
here we go
oh okay I think I'm good all right what
are we what are what are the categories
let's do some initial judgments just
before our parents appearance what looks
like the most appetizing the one you'd
want to dig into that pie I mean that
pie is beautiful I think presentation on
that pie is but this shows some
fruitiness which
makes me want to eat it that scares me
that little that terrifies me like if it
did the thing in cartoons where did the
the waft II and I were like drawn by the
smell that's you know food is very
important about how it looks but man
that is the most impulsive thing that's
it I gotta say that does look good
though but I would have liked to have
like more of a cross hatching on that
mice and lattice yeah this texture looks
great but yeah lattice even if you
couldn't do the interweaving just like
blah blah blah blah blah I think that
would have made it look a lot more
appealing because it is just a lot of
open space that being said and this is
not just me being greedy this did turn
out nicely it's kinda nice crust I think
oh okay I see what you're talking about
yeah now how is it there we go see and
if you push on it it push steena if that
talks to me before I either on initial
appearance I get the win on that one
presentation babe so let's go let's
plate it you whoever wants to go first
okay make sure you get some ten in there
who knows maybe this tastes really good
I don't think so oh no oh no hey that
looks okay
oh god it looks pretty awful actually
looks like I'm really dried Oh Bob it's
doesn't like us to have other
this is everything this is a problem no
apples are in here oh there big chunks
so that that's what I didn't get there
they're large chunks of apples Leakey it
must be the layers it's a little too
crispy the outside edges that drooped
over they did they did crisp up quite a
bit
it doesn't look awful it's a bit thin I
didn't have as much filling as I
would've liked and I think having more
filling would have made it a bit more
robust and maybe like kept it from
drying out a bit but that's quite play
ooh man it smells a bit of play-doh Wow
someone didn't love this no this doesn't
have any knees in it does it
okay that does look good not a very
generous piece though mark and I cut out
Big Boy
I think by his volume now this being
said right here the layering does look
at the pastry on the bottom does look
good but I just wish there was something
on the top okay so from plating I gotta
give it a dialer that's plated super
well Tyler's is holding its shape
probably that flour mine just didn't
have enough volume and it's crucian out
the sides anyway yours where mine's
overly juicy yours is the opposition to
dry this somehow sucked all of the
moisture out of it I like the tail I
don't like so now it all comes up to
taste this is my category all right I
guess I'll try yours first more pieces
than one yeah
Kranti it's like pita bread the fillings
okay except the fact that it tastes like
worse Apple but I didn't microwave might
be it's not like if if I had that at a
restaurant I would be so mad boy
if my friend cooked that for me I would
secretly be mad when I wouldn't say to
their face it's not so bad that I would
openly insult them I mean that scenarios
what is happening now yeah yeah yeah no
if you just came over to my house look I
baked you a pie I'd be so happy that you
bake me a pie but then secretly
afterwards I'd want you to leave cuz I I
would debate whether it was a trick you
know what I mean and honestly the
filling just tastes like Apple yeah you
got on with the pita bread it's like a
toasted all right this looks really good
I like the way though I actually got
some layers out of that I'm yeah ooh
that is some good crust the crust is a
bit chewy mm-hmm but the filling is
really good it's the right amount of
sugar and the right amount of fruit
mixture and you can taste all the
different fruits and it's really good I
like your filling a lot right that
feeling is really really good right yeah
the question is well once you get under
the initial yeah
if you made this pie for me like you did
right now I'd be like it's not like oh
you got some work to do but that's a
good start I would be like you did great
on the filling but the crust needs work
yeah and like I would just take the
crust off and eat that filling straight
that's a really good thing you're right
that that that filling did I somehow got
the sweetness right because it tastes
really good you've actually made pies
before right I made one pie and followed
the recipe it was a caramel apple pie
with a little bit of doctoring and I did
a lattice crust and you you and Amy ate
it you both liked it Oh mm-hmm
you went back for a second slice that's
really good really good really good it's
hard to get it's hard to know what the
cross is like because there's not much
there I'm not with all the filling on
top of it it's all right I like what the
crust is like right but good filling it
good it's really your filling is quite
good not cake eh I thought it was gonna
be and the cross that I do get it's a
little on the chilly side but it's not
nearly as as bad as that I'm really
intrigued by this hot yep yeah that was
real good no no what Tyler I would like
a slice of your pot oh I'm gonna stick
with my pie
I like your but I would not like I
wouldn't all right so as far as a winner
goes overall I guess a Tyler got this
yeah you didn't win anything I can't
think of a single redeeming quality
about you'd be winning it so that is it
for this
Marta bar mix Thank You Ethan Thank You
Tyler for being here with us and thank
you everybody so much for watching we
don't just have to stop here there's
other kinds of pies we can make we can
make pumpkin pie key lime pie we can
milk this category for all it's worth
so thank you everybody so much meringue
driver Ryan rings or we could try
cheesecake which we was it ever
determined to be a cake or a listen
Herrmann as a cake I don't care either
way let us know other things we can make
down the comments below check out all
the other markiplier mix in the
description and thank you
watching and as always I'll see you in
the next video bye bye
bye